garder espoir malgré le silence très
pesant en l'absence de sa fille âgée de
22 ans
depuis sept mois c'est le quotidien
d'evelyne la mère de aude jean alexis le
plus douloureux pour cette maman qui
s'exprime aujourd'hui entendre et voir
circuler des propos diffamatoires sous
les réseaux sociaux
j'ai entendu tellement de personnes qui
parlait en son nom et en os
mon nom alors j'ai préféré privilégier
l'enquète et aujourd'hui je sors de
londres parce que je ne veux plus qu'on
parle à la place de ma vie et à la place
c'est le 11 novembre dernier que odh
laisse le cartilage à rivière salée en
direction du bourg et c'est là qu'elle
disparaît aude envisager de passer son
permis de conduire elle enchaînait donc
les petits boulots en intérim comme ici
dans cette grande surface du lamentin le
15 novembre
c'est d'ailleurs le responsable de
l'agencé terrine qui informe sa mère de
son absence au travail indique annie
rivés sur son lieu de travail
j'y suis tout de suite instinct de mère
et puis surtout je connais les habitudes
de food elle ne loupe pas son travail
vous avez tenté de la joindre sur son
portable arbitres premier réflexe
facebook appelé d'abord aude et de
facebook
je savais qu'il y avait quelque chose
aux matelles dix fois par jour
retracer le mystérieux par claude gaudin
à partir du bourg de rivière salée 1
plutôt compliqué pour les enquêteurs
des affiches sont apposés dans plusieurs
secteurs
la section de recherches est encore très
active sur le terrain elle ne néglige
aucune piste aux jo
alexis ou est elle été enlevée et
séquestrée en martinique ou ailleurs sa
mère lance un appel je m'adresse à des
éventuels
ravisseurs s'il y en a puisqu'on ne sait
pas est ce qu'ils ont envie de vivre
avec quelque chose sur la conscience où
est ce qu'ils ont envie d'être humain
donc j'attends j'attends un appel un
signe de quelqu'un de ces personnes d'où
de cette personne ou de haut tout
simplement